at this north yorkshire farm water isn't
normally a problem but natural springs
are at their lowest levels in years and
it's not rained properly in months since
the end of april it rained on the 7th of
june 3 week gone thursday and then
saturday night those are the three bits
of room we've had but we have the rest
of july and all august to come yet which
are the two months of summer
this is a cow and sheep farm and it
relies on grass for its livestock but
where there should be lush green pasture
lack of rain has left brown fields and
barren earth there is so so little
vegetation green nutritious grass of any
sort for them to graze
there's quite a lot of ground to go out
in you know in this field in the shape
up a big stray to run out but there's
just nowhere anywhere left where there's
any grass growing what impact does that
have on on the sheep their health
they're not producing milk for the lambs
the lambs are needing milk they're still
dependent on the mothers so they're
again quite thin they're not growing
like they should be growing they're pot
bedding looking very miserable and sad
farmers like keith say that if this
current dry spell continues food
security cannot be guaranteed
and officials today warned that parts of
england could soon be in a drought
when the land is already as dry as this
rainfall in the next few weeks however
significant it is isn't really going to
help this land and remember there is
acre upon acre of it is already too dry
to recover but where it will be
significant that rain if it comes is
helping to grow new grass and that will
help feed livestock like these sheep
over winter and it will also crucially
help reduce fire risks on land that is
absolutely parched
we've seen how dry conditions have
fueled fires
and shrunk levels in rivers and
reservoirs
today officials said there are no
guarantees of more rain to come
it looks like there will be a lot of dry
weather around in the next few weeks
especially for the southern half of the
uk at least with the bulk of any
significant rainfall
in the far north and northwest
in fact forecasters warn of another heat
wave this weekend and next week as
extreme temperatures driven by climate
change prompt calls for urgent action i
think it should be a wake-up call but it
shouldn't be a one-off it shouldn't just
be a news story it should be um the kind
of time that radicalizes lots of people
time that makes people
um
feel energized and feel motivated take
action
tomorrow there will be an urgent
government-led meeting about the
possible drought to look at what
restrictions might be necessary to
guarantee water supplies and keep
everyone safe catherine of totsy sky
news